reject nation we're gonna watch
ourselves the next episode of gravity
falls hit that like button if you can
also major major thank you to the boys
at prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights full length watch
laundry sync up with the time code over
at our patreon page check out all we
gotta offer over there thanks to all
become superjects let's fall in love
with the gravity
[Music]
here we are the summerween superstore
the people of this town love halloween
so much they celebrate it twice a year
and wouldn't you know it it's today
something about this feels unnatural
when the children come to my door
tonight they're gonna run away screaming
from stan pines master of fright
you're a natural stan
have the police come and eject the pines
family from the store not today
they just stole that you paid for the
stuff right of course
i hate summerween
oh let's move
poor lady she deserves her revenge yeah
she's at a seasonal job those can be
grueling it's a night of cools and
goblins not to mention
the summerween trickster
he's a pervert
well you don't have to worry about us
we've got spirit to go around
oh what is this stuff i've never even
heard of these brands sand pop oh mr
adequate bar
this is all cheap oh loser team work the
candy your cape is caught in your fly
seuss
too sure
that doesn't discredit the trickster
oh oh you're breaking the rules
shut up robbie of course he's not going
trick-or-treating no yeah
uh trick-or-treating is for babies oh
you should come to this party with us
tambry's parents are out of town and
it's gonna be off the chain not
surprised you didn't hear about it
nine dollars oh at night okay
that's late
a school night
i am so sweet i could eat myself hello
mr pines you got a cold honey
is waddles coming with us i wish you
could but you've got some very important
meetings to attend
oh
you little gentlemen where's your summer
ween spirit
trick or treat
wow
you're a little old for this man sorry
but wait i told you mabel i'm just not
feeling it tonight
i think a little trick-or-treating will
make you feel better i'm not
trick-or-treating
have some dignity man
i apologize for my brother he came down
with the case of the grumpy grumps
silence
you have insulted me
and for this you must pay
with your lives
you're a funny guy aren't you
funny am i
trick or treat my name
[Music]
i is collect 500 pieces of gandy and
bring it to me before the last jackal
melon goes out
oh [ __ ] you must trick-or-treat
or die
oh my gosh mabel do you know what this
means i do
it means you have to come
trick-or-treating
that's one way to look at it yeah glass
half full what's going on out here dudes
i heard a ruckus
that's a funny word ruckus arrakis
the spice with candy spirit grinder
strengths dipper's brains and
seuss here we'll get 500 pieces of candy
and have fun doing it too why don't you
just buy it
oh yeah
it's probably on sale already trick or
treat
what can i do for you
oh no no
huh can we have candy now what's the
matter with you kids that was the
scariest thing you've ever seen right
yeah
gosh real very real gut
[Laughter]
we're not scared
you will be
it's a very plan nine right there that's
a really impressive effect he did yeah i
want to learn how to do that
oh and what are you supposed to be
uh actually i'm not dressed up as
anything we're kind of in a hurry here
oh i see
oh
dude dipper you're screwing them over
four pieces of candy this is gonna take
forever you gotta put on your costume i
told you i'm not up to it mabel
oh really
look how spidery they made him
this dude is messed up yeah
oh no
yeah
candy
[Music]
you gave it your all waddles watch this
what what is this
[Laughter]
for the first time in public
peanut butter and jelly
oh do you really think this will make a
difference
[Music]
wonderful let's get that candy guys
they just might do this
[Music]
no hurry
that's just my face this is a mask
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm gonna go around and grab the truck
last one to the final house is a pair of
wax lamp not me no
don't box us i'm gonna go to wendy's
party and no one needs to know i was
trick-or-treating no
no
hide
hey dipper oh hey wendy i'm on my way i
like watching the trick-or-treaters see
you there
later guys
you're going to a party
oh
no
that's why you were acting so weird and
trying to hurry us you're not sick at
all so if it wasn't for this crazy
monster you are gonna ditch me oh
what happened to the dipper who used to
love halloween
and where's all the candy relax relax i
left it right here behind this book oh
god no oh no
no
oh
damn it
[Music]
good night
what's happening just don't blow out
that candle
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry
[Music]
where's my candy
i swear we had all 500 pieces look it's
down there somewhere we can still get it
oh no
that was your last chance
[Music]
[Laughter]
gross no
avenge them
whoa whoa
that wasn't like a regular pedestrian
was it
[Laughter]
just glad it's over right
nah dude you screwed up
let's go
oh
hey are you okay
there are probably some bandages back at
the shack
oh my god
he's like the liquid terminator
[Music]
he's like that guy from spirited away
if he was also like freddy krueger
oh oh my god it's the co-worker who's
doing all this
employee
oh
i don't know how she's doing
[Laughter]
i felt like i was getting a little too
old to go trick-or-treating that's
exactly why we need to go
trick-or-treating dipper we're getting
older there's not that many halloweens
left i guess i didn't realize it was
already our last one
[Music]
what if it sees us if only there was
something we could use to cover our
bodies and faces with
almost there
zeus
stop
zeus don't you dare sorry dude today's
been quite stressful i need some levity
[Music]
oh thank goodness it was out of
batteries
[Laughter]
ahead
[Laughter]
this cockling head's the voice of a
generation
[Music]
oh
it's all water taffy grumps
what are you
wait it is you really haven't figured it
out yet
where is it all the rejected candy
look at my face look closely
oh
did you ever stop and think about the
candy at the bottom of the bag that no
one likes
children of gravity falls throw away all
of the rejected candy into the dump
so i seek revenge
no one would eat me
but now i'm going to eat you
what is that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
dude you want some of this you actually
think i taste
good uh sure you know all that never
wanted is for someone to say that i was
good
crying makes it a little weird but
i guess i'm still eating oh ew
what's up corny i've been traumatized
you'll be all right buddy let's get our
candy all
[Applause]
old
ready
[Music]
you got this man
oh oh goodness flush off the shave stan
wash off the shame
he thought he could scare us
oh no
it's a decent exposure
still got it
hey stan hi grunkle stan hello hello mr
pines how's it hanging hey dipper
wendy oh where were you uh i uh
i was trick-or-treating
with my sister
yeah um the party was lame anyway robby
ate a lollipop stick first and had to go
home sick oh
we went to every single house and we
didn't even get to eat any candy candy
how's that for candy oh that's right
at the end of the day summerween isn't
about candy or costumes or even scaring
people it's a day when the whole family
can get together in one place and
celebrate what really matters pure
evil
nice i ate a man alive tonight
dankest memes
hey that's how they got the idea for
that black mirror episode
if you say kids watching
yeah watch the first episode of black
mirror oh yeah that ever aired trust me
it has a pig in it
if you like pigs from gravity falls
you're gonna love that i love that yeah
it's equally as adorable a pig
first things first i should clarify if
you're a kid don't watch that episode of
blackbeard no
maybe don't even if you're an adult
depending on your sensibilities
yeah that was rough you got to take a
shower once you finish it all right john
tell me about your favorite episode of
why you love this song
i mean why would you assume that this
episode is tailor made for me to love it
summer wins your favorite time of year
that's right well i mean to be fair it's
usually around the time i start getting
into the halloween spirit when i was a
kid it was like okay
it's like late may i'm gonna start
drawing jack-o'-lanterns let's do this
so uh yeah yeah i am totally down with
the concept of celebrating halloween
half and then most of the way through
the year as well
uh
you know i'm obviously going to be urged
into carving a watermelon a jack of
melon uh but no i mean i thought like i
don't know as the halloween episode as
the you know summerween episode i
thought they did nicely to both make the
holiday their own and then do a nice
riff tribute
on
i feel like
there's an aspect where like yeah
they're a bunch of horror movie villains
that are amalgamated to make up the
summerween trickster or prankster or
whatever he's called um but i like that
this also has that very
distinct halloween flavor because not
like most horror movies aren't halloween
movies too so uh you know
there are a few you would think of for
halloween time which is like michael
myers and maybe these days sam from
trick or treat but i like that yeah you
have like a lot of horror movie in
general
homage in that particular character and
then you just have the fun of halloween
which i am just tailor-made to eat right
up like whatever candy and i'm gonna go
hey i mean i probably could have helped
out because i love candy corn all right
he was crying candy corn i was like i
know it gets a bad rap but uh every year
i'm i'm about it
classic candy corn the autumn mixed
candy corn little pumpkins in it that's
good brown sugar ones all about it love
a good costume
true yeah what do you think g what do
you think
i think you should be giving kids fruit
on halloween and vegetables okay
the concept of giving kids food filled
with the high sugar high fructose corn
syrup artificially processed and then
having them consume it on mass amounts
and encouraging such behavior
is really damaging to the
biological development of a child and
also can affect their brain as well i
think it encourages a very unhealthy
lifestyle
of course yeah i agree i think that is
uh this episode is uh is an abomination
a lot of ways
of biblical proportions
so
damn this show to hell
along with its creators yeah
however on the flip side if i were to
play devil's advocate i would say that
this is a really well executed concept i
didn't see the reveal coming did you not
not in any uh far advanced kind of way i
put it together seconds before
nice but uh you know that's not really
much to lean on
nah you don't get credit for seconds
before the deal when they're about to
tell you and they probably indicated
enough
i didn't put together until seconds
later after it was explained
and then i was like clever stuff but you
know the way of capturing the spirit of
you know being able to trick-or-treat
during halloween
that no matter how old you get and you
know i feel like i'm too old to
trick-or-treat but that's why i'm always
looking for some kid to take with me so
it doesn't look weird the only weird
part is getting the kid
that's the part where you come across
weird yeah when you're trying to scout a
child to take around so you can go
trick-or-treating again
um let me be clear about my intentions
right now i'm in this for the candidate
the life experience nothing else man you
get 50 of the cut
so
it's actually a little short film that
we made there
there is there's a very charming and
also very uh cringy short film depending
on how you do it yeah it is a fun little
film that we made there a very guy who
wants to recapture his youth that feels
uncomfortable to go trick-or-treating so
he needs to find a kid to befriend but
that could be creepy yeah
oh there's so many fun there's a funny
way to do it
yeah i just don't go down the rabbit
hole of going all freaking you know lars
von sure about
it because i know laura's volunteer he's
made some really good family-friendly
moves yes yes yes absolutely uh so yeah
i think that concept is really um is
really really cute you know i miss
trick-or-treating and i think the last
time i went i did go like i am a little
too old for this but you know i i prefer
trick-or-treating over parties any day
parties just make me uncomfortable it's
like it doesn't feel like it's really
about having a good costume
and so yeah kids if you're watching
don't worry about the [ __ ]
with your shirts off
just enjoy yourself you know yeah if you
go to a halloween party try to make it a
halloween party that still does like
halloween party stuff along with people
dancing to
contemporary pop music you could hear
anytime
sorry also too for using the word [ __ ]
that sounds like i'm [ __ ] shaming by
saying that
um i didn't mean to go all joe rogan on
you guys oh no
misinformation i want all my music taken
off of youtube until they remove you i
know it sounds like i'm talking about
[ __ ]
but that's not what i meant in the
context
end of quote joe
yes
i don't have to elaborate whatsoever
yeah no you're you're iron clad right
here i agree
uh so yeah uh this was a this was a
really pleasant one and i think the way
they realized the monster was genuinely
inventive and creepy
and uh this is another solid installment
of gravity falls and i like also grunkle
stan this deals a lot with it's like
coming of age and having to deal with
you know how much
you've uh have you lost it still have
you lost that semblance of youth
with the kids trying to grow up and not
appreciating this moment in time
creating memories and then also grunkle
stan feeling like he's gotta
still capture that ability to horrify
young children
and the way he does it is by exposing
him yes
which is gonna oh which would next year
is he gonna do that intentionally is my
question
like this could get this could get hairy
you know
although i i i very much appreciated the
kids uh showing him the prank video the
meme the meme loud meme video yeah
shit's scary and i was surprised we
never saw that blood
oh the fake blood yeah yeah he brought
like three drums of fake blood and i was
like there's gotta be a shining bit in
here although
you know it's disney xd i i doubt that
they would be like yes even fake let's
just have a wave of blood you never know
man but that head melting effect was
legitimate yeah that was was really well
done doesn't get enough credit for his
practical effects that he does grunkle
stan probably used to work in special
effects all right guys what do you think
let's do a page
rosa parra rosa you would be such a
blasty blast to go trick-or-treating
with you and your family we can get them
all dressed up right like you dress up
as like a ooh a spooky witch like it and
john's like a vampire and and then i'm
like like a ghoul
and then your children your three kids
the first ones like jeffrey dahmer the
second one would be like ted bundy your
third one because your latino would be
richard ramirez
imagine that just going around just fun
costumes for everyone terrifying like
taking pictures with people taking
photos being like oh my children are
obsessed with richard ramirez
they love these
shows and podcasts and like we always
listen to them on the way to school
and now here we are getting to live out
these fantasies and passions for them so
i just think it would be great if we
could all go trick-or-treating together
this year um us obviously in more mature
outfits but your children being
kid-friendly
about it all i love you thank you so
much for being part of our patreon page
for so
long i'll talk to you soon
[Music]